vous voulez voir hermès on cherche son
fils c'est très un pareil jugement
d'autres vu la façon dont vous avez fait
irruption
vous êtes hermès je suis un tantinet
vexé que vous ne m'ayez pas reconnu mon
amour-propre aura presque plus en
souffrir si je n'avais pas autant
confiance en moi je ne sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais je suis un vrai dieu
en sorte
vous avez ma cravate je viens de
m'offrir hermès évidemment tout vrai
grand vos yeux
équipement de pointe pour le tri et le
traitement et l'emballage en tout cas si
vous croisez son chemin ou sauf nous en
préserve si vous croisez l'épée nous ce
ne serait pas une mauvaise chose que
vous ayez un petit truc ou deux pour
vous protéger
accessoires collector davis et le
bouchon et vous déchaîner les vents
depuis les quatre coins du monde
franchement c'est pas de couilles ok
vous vous aurez aussi besoin de ceux ci
je tiens dans mes mains un éliminateur
de matières marques déposées tracer le
contour d'un objet avec ça et il
disparaît en voulez encore merci
il n'y arrivera pas